hello everyone welcome to today's live
broadcast regulation of mrna translation
by ribosomes we are delighted to bring
you this educational web seminar
presented by levers I am Judy O'Rourke
and I'll be your moderator for today's
event we have a few important
announcements before we begin this
webcast is designed to be interactive
and we encourage you to ask questions
during the event you can submit
questions by typing them in the Q&A box
which can be found by clicking on the
green Q&A button at the lower left of
the presentation window we'll try to
answer as many questions as we can you
can enlarge the slide window by clicking
on the screen icon in the lower right
hand corner of the slide window if you
have any technical problems viewing or
hearing this presentation please click
on the support button at the top right
of your presentation window or submit
your problems agreeing to an a button
lower left I would now like to introduce
today's speaker Vincent tomorrow PhD
doctor Moro is senior vice president and
chief scientific officer for chromosome
and an adjunct associate professor
scripps research institute i will now
turn it over to dr. morrow for his
presentation thank you thank you Judy
and I'd like to thank lab roots entire
conference ride for this for this
opportunity so translation as we as we
all know is one of the most highly
conserved mechanisms in in biology the
genetic code is essentially universal
except for a few exceptions the
translation machinery is highly
conserved across kingdoms to ribosomes
subunits the components RNA and protein
or aspects of the ribosomes are even
very very similar even from e.coli to
human and the the of the importance of
translation is in synthesizing proteins
in translating the genetic code but
there's another aspect to ribosomes
which until the last few years wasn't
wasn't well appreciated which is a
regulatory aspect and so that that's
that's what I'm going to talk about in
in this presentation so he'll begin with
a little background on translation
initiation and then ribosomes I'll
discuss the revs and filter hypothesis
which has been postulated the regulatory
role look of ribosomes and they don't
give a few examples from from our lab
primarily on interactions affecting
specific regulation through ribosomal
RNA and I'll touch on a few other
examples which highlight some important
variants of the the notion of ribosomal
regulation and at the end I'll just
touch on maybe some of the more
synthetic aspects of gravel regulation
so taking it from the natural to to a
more synthetic situation and so as as
background this this diagram illustrates
the flow of genetic information from the
DNA to the mRNA to the protein and our
interest is in is in translation
translation step and so the mRNA itself
as indicated has a coding region and
most eukaryotic mrnas have a single
coding region that encodes my protein on
either side of the coding region are
typically untranslated regions turn the
five prime leader and the three prime
untranslated region and so for the
process of translating the genetic code
into protein involves several steps and
solely the mRNA is translated by
translation machinery so ribosomes in
the cell former an initiation complex at
start site and which is typically Aug
which includes Matheny once that complex
is formed the ribosome can decode the
mRNA and synthesize a polypeptide chain
and at a certain point there are their
codons that specify termination and at
that point the ribosomes can can
dissociate the the peptide that's being
synthesized is released and the RNA and
the ribosomes can can be recycled and
this can happen again so the actual
initiation of translation can also
involves a couple of steps and so this
is a process whereby the small ribosomal
subunit and the mRNA get together and
there are a number of different ways
that this can happen so for example one
of the most common mechanisms it's shown
in front of the top so this this
mechanism here cap dependent mrna
translation some eukaryotic mRNAs
contain a post-transcriptional
modification on their mrnas and m7 jia
methylated nucleotide called the cap
structure in this cap structure can
interact with various proteins in the
cell called initiation factors that can
mediate an interaction between the mRNA
and the 40s ribosomal subunit now that
this is this is a major mechanism of
recruitment in the cells but recruitment
can occur other ways so there are a
number of different mechanisms that
involve internal initiation cap
independent initiation in translation
that doesn't require the cap and so
their specific sequence is called
internal ribosome entry sites irises
that can facilitate the recruitment of
ribosomes at sites within the message
there are cysts sequences that can in
some cases interact directly with the
ribosomal subunit in some kittens of
emphasis this is this region and so this
is demonstrating it for illustrating a
direct
interaction between assists sequence and
40s ribosomal subunit you can also have
in direct recruitment some of the some
of the mechanisms involve the same
initiation factors that are used to
recruit at the caf they may involve a
subset of these factors that may involve
non-canonical factor so there appear to
be not the cap independent really
appears to be a very generat mechanism
that allows a lot of different different
mechanisms to recruit the ribosome it if
it appears that almost any interaction
between the mRNA and component of the
translation machinery can get the
ribosome to the message in either event
if you're recruiting at the cap or if
you're recruiting by cap independent
mechanism the the ribosome needs to find
a place to start initiating and this is
typically an Aug codon and the
recognition occurs through an initiator
methionine tRNA which base pairs to the
Aug coda so in bacteria what happens is
at least in the shine-dalgarno
interaction which is best characterized
the initiation event the ribosome is
recruited immediately adjacent to the
Aug codon and so it's there it's already
placed there it doesn't have to doesn't
have to move anywhere but in most
eukaryotic mrnas that's not the case the
ribosomes are not being recruited right
at the initiation codon they are
typically recruited quite a distance
upstream it can be hundreds of base
could be over a thousand bases upstream
and so that the ribosome has to get from
the site of recruitment to the
initiation codon now how the hell it
occurs it's still not really fully
understood there are various mechanisms
that have been postulated including
linear scanning and not only
near mechanisms that involve ribosome
Ashanti now the widely-held model is the
scanning model of ribosomal movement and
so the scanning hypothesis so in this
cartoon we show green ribosomal 40s
ribosomal subunit coming in at the cap
and moving to the initiator start site
and so the idea here is that the
ribosomal subunit was linearly along the
five prime non-coding region until it
encounters an Aug proton so it's a base
by base inspection and once the first
Aug codon is encountered or at least an
Aug codon that resides in what's
considered a good nucleotide context and
tyranny can buying base pair scanning
stops once this scanning stops the large
60s subunit comes in forms an 80s
complex and the ribosome is then ready
to start protein synthesis so that this
the cartoon I have here in is kind of
illustrating initiation of the five
prime end of the message but it's also
been postulated that scanning is
occurring when a ribosome is coming in
at an internal point in the message for
example an iris I think it's important
to keep in mind that although the
scanning hypothesis is consistent with
the translation of summer RNAs it's it's
only and supported by indirect evidence
so for example scanning ribosomes have
never been visualized in the personal
energy source that's ever been
identified for the scanning which which
would be required to destabilize or any
secondary structures fact it's been
shown that you can remove from the site
of recruitment to the initiation codon
without ATP and then there are a number
of observations that seem to be
inconsistent with scanning for example
not allow mrnas initiated the first Aug
in human something like forty percent of
mrnas do not initiate it at the first
Aug code on the initiation codon is is
not always the codon in best context
oftentimes the upstream aug codons are
done a nucleotide context and should
should be preferentially used excited in
fact if you look at AG distribution in
five prime leaders it appears to her by
chance and then kind of an interesting
observation is that obstacles that
should block scanning for example very
stable stem loop structures sometimes
lock scanning and other times have no
effect at all and very interesting
observation is that oftentimes if you
have to Aug codons that are close to
each other they appear to compete for
ribosomes and for example in a very nice
study and it was a turn up the elbow
mosaic virus two closely spaced Aug
codons were both utilized and many
studies have shown utilization of one
purple Aug codons but what was
interesting here is that when the second
Aug quote on was progressively spaced
further from the first the use of the
first one went up which is inconsistent
with a uni-directional scanning model
and suggest that the ribosome is
sampling and go to the next slide so
there are no shunting models are
nonlinear models of initiation that have
been suggested as well and again this is
the same sort of cartoons try to
illustrate the principle the top is a
scanning mechanism that is by passing a
segment of the five prime leader and so
the knee arrow is showing that were
jumping and jumping over a region of the
five-run leader it's also been
postulated that the chunky might occur
without scanning at all and so that this
is the second the second cartoon here
kind of illustrates that where
the ribosome is kind of moving from spot
to spot and the things such as a shunt
donor and acceptor sites have been
postulated that we interact with the
subunit and mediate this sort of
nonlinear movement and you know the
final cartoon here illustrates what
might occur if you're going directly
from the site of recruitment to any
initiation codon without scanning or
intermediate shunting an idea in a
further developed in some of some of our
work and so a model that was proposed by
my colleagues and I Sistine Chapel and
the late Gerald Edelman is the ribosomal
tethering and clustering hypothesis in
this was proposed to try to explain
translation of many of the messages that
we were working on and many of the
examples in the literature that seemed
to be completely innocent inconsistent
with scanning and so the idea in a
tethered complex and shown on the left
here would be that the way it's drawn
the ribosomal subunits tethered to the
cap but this this tethered interaction
could occur at internal sites of me in
the message as well and the idea is that
the initiator Matheny tRNA would just
directly bind to an Aug codon and so the
variables that would come into play here
are the distance between the ribosome
and the Aug code on the accessibility of
the Aug corner so you can imagine that
Aug quote on that might be too close to
the complex might not be very
efficiently used because trust Eric
reasons and as you get further and
further from the site of recruitment
initiation would be predicted to be less
efficient because of the distance you
might also imagine that
an Aug codon might be more accessible if
it were it were might be more likely to
be used if we were more accessible and
so for example an Aug proton was buried
in secondary structure it might not be
available to base pair to the initiator
tRNA if I fan AAG Quran is covered by a
protein or protein complex again it
might not be accessible to base pairing
and studies from our from our laboratory
have have supported that idea now the
clustering mechanism is is a variation
it's a similar idea the ribosome makes
interactions with sequence elements
within the mRNA so these are not as
stable as when we predict an ax in a
tether for example the cap these are
interactions that inform and associate
and so by having a more of one or more
mRNA elements that can mediate these
types of interactions the idea is that
the local concentration of the the
ribosomal subunits would be increased
and so the likelihood of making an
initiation event of finding an AEG code
on the other tyranny will be increased
in the vicinity look upstream and
downstream and our experiments have
suggested that that that is the case and
so some predictions of this model are
one that the ribosomes are reaching the
initiation codon without a nucleotide by
nucleotide inspection of the five prime
leader the basic idea of both feathering
clustering is that you have an increased
local concentration that increases the
likelihood of an initiation event in the
vicinity and an important prediction is
that initiation is not restricted to one
site but they kind of curve from
different sites within mrnas including
from the coding region and their last
two or three years or so there have been
a lot of data coming out that
really support this idea the translation
is occurring from multiple sites in
frame and out of frame from canonical
and non-canonical initiation programs
and so pro Mazzone company that i
co-founded has has used these ideas to
develop two technologies that have been
units to enhanced protein production one
is called rescue which involves some
recording of the primary nucleotide
sequence and te es which are translation
in enhancing elements and these are
these are technologies that have been
developed for increasing the production
of protein drugs for example in a in a
bioreactor and so that the ribosomal
tethering and clustered model can
account for for numerous observations
for example shunting these ribosomal
interactions with ribosomal RNA
interactions don't require scanning
because these if these interactions can
mediate different binding events along
the message these models predict the
translation is going to occur at
different points depending on the
message depending on the the distance
the structure the RNA binding proteins
and so on so it doesn't predict that
translation would always occur at the
first Aug going on and it gives us an
exploit an explanation why can explain
why closely spaced Aug qur'an's can
compete with each other and it can also
explain why secondary structure there
are sometimes inhibitory to translation
and sometimes they're not in fact if you
look at some of that literature what you
find is that as a stable structure like
a hairpin structure if it's in the
middle of a longer sequence and
sometimes it's completely bypassed it's
closer to for example the cap structure
or if it's closer to the aeg codon what
happens is often times it is inhibitory
and it may be that in those cases
its inhibitory because of the steric
effects where it may be blocking a
binding of the translation machinery or
affecting the accessibility of the
started site and then I began mention it
to variables that affect translation
where translation is going to occur it's
going to be different in different
messages depending on the sequence on
the structure and associated factors so
now if we look at if we look at
ribosomes so as I mentioned earlier
these are highly conserved through
evolution and here we have bacterial and
new carry otic ribosomes and so the main
the main function is to catalyze peptide
synthesis long cases that composed of
two subunits there's in the middle here
this common core so commented to the
bacterial and the eukaryotic the RNAs in
these and these subunits are shown in
blue and the proteins are shown in red
and so there you can see that big
massive of RNA and peppered with
RevZilla proteins and and and so there
are there common elements and there are
specific elements and so as you kind of
grow up higher into the higher
eukaryotes well what becomes distinctive
are kind of these extensions indicated
by these kind of got it lines with which
our expansion segments and so there are
segments of the ribosomal RNA that are
longer in the eukaryotic that in the in
the bacterial it means our apps into the
bacteria so for example in the mammalian
emptiness when there's 12 expansion
segments and so these are these are
segments that are more
it or not not concerned through
evolution they tend to be on the surface
they tend to be variable in length in
different species and and so as the
ribosome has kind of evolved it's gotten
bigger and it contains more of these
what might be less essential molecules
features and and so as a we don't know
the primary role of the ribosome is
peptide synthesis but a number of
different observations suggest that they
also can have important roles in
regulating translation and and so kind
of going back a few years what will kind
of got me interested in this whole area
well ribosomal RNA like sequences so at
the time was working on cell adhesion
and looking at changes in gene
expression as a consequence of cell
adhesion events and what we observed was
one the cell adhesion events can affect
the expression of cell adhesion on
consultants was interesting but there
were there were a couple of other
observations that a little bit more
looking it wasn't restricted to cell
adhesion but almost every type of
comparison revealed messages that had
ribosomal RNA like sequences so these
are sequins short sequence elements
within mrnas that either resemble
ribosomal RNA or complementary to the
ribosomal RNA and kind of a simple
listen kind of a simple-minded idea at
the time was you know maybe these
sequences that are complementary might
just base pair to ribosomes like the end
of bacteria and sequences that resemble
it might interact with ribosomal
proteins and that might be a mechanism
of regulation as well then another
another thing that came out of those
studies will represent protein mrnas of
it so
different conditions cell adhesion and
other different experimental paradigms
that you find is expression of some
ribosomal protein mrnas is enhanced and
others is be created and it appears to
be very specific and it's different
representing mrnas in each case and so
this kind of raised the the idea that
well maybe other different conditions or
different cell types there's a the
ribosome the structure of the ribosome
is kind of actively being remodeled and
this may face may have functional
significance and I think there have been
a kind of a literature some
heterogeneity and going back many years
and at that time a lot of those studies
we're not taking too seriously because
because of technical issues but this is
a this is something that appears to be
holding up even today and more and more
examples are coming out indicating that
this is the case any other interesting
observation was that specific mutations
in individual ribosomal proteins
oftentimes have very specific effects
for example
blood disorders order skeletal
abnormalities and which is not likely
which is not exactly what you might
anticipate if if it was if a mutation
was having kind of a general inhibitory
effect on the ribosome dozen of these
were some interesting observations and
so we formulated we being me and really
Gary Edelman formulated the ribosome
filter hypothesis to try to explain some
of these observations and at the time I
wasn't really what kind of viewed as as
tape heads that were just decoding mrna
and traveling along another that's what
they do and that's that's a very
important function but based on some of
the things I've told you and various
observations postulated that the
ribosomes also have regulatory capacity
in this this regulation that can affect
the expression of different mRNAs based
on the ability of ribosomes to
differentially interact with subsets of
the mRNA population so the ribosome
filter hypothesis postulates that the
ribosome is a regulatory element that
embodies mechanisms for preferentially
translating particular subsets of the
message population and so the focus of a
lot of our work has been on interactions
between the ribosomal RNA and the mRNA
and I'll discuss a couple of examples of
that that there there are also
interactions between ribosomal mrnas and
ribosomal proteins that can affect
translation and I don't mention some
examples of that as well so in another
feature of the hypothesis as a ribosomes
are possibility to have a continuum of
regulatory effects so some interactions
are prostituted to enhance translation
enhance the probability of an initiation
event and others are posited to to be
inhibitory to down regulate expression
the ability of messages and ribosomes to
interact via specific binding sites
suggests that different rnase may
compete for binding to those sites and
so there there may be effects caused by
this competition and we postulate that
one one way to modulate the filter is to
is to have situations in which the the
particular binding sites are altered
inaccessibility that could be masked
ribosomal RNA there are variants of
ribosomal RNA there are differences in
ribosomal protein composition that could
enable certain sites to binding sites to
be present or absence either in a
ribosomal protein or in the ribosomal
RNA itself but asking or allowing
sequences to be accessible and as well
as other proteins or rnase that might
interact with subunits and affect
potential particular binding sites and
so this is a cartoon that tries to
illustrate the notion of how ribosomes
that are differ in protein or RNA in the
presence or absence of different binding
sites might differentially affect
translation of messages and so the top
these these circles are supposed to be
ribosomes and so there's a green and red
bar in ribosome a and these are these
would be binding sites the green
represents a binding site that would
would enhance translation the red
indicates of mining site that would
inhibit translation and so an a/b both
of these binding sites are present and
accessible
it's something to be the green the
positive binding site is present the
other side is is absent or it's being
masked concedes its the negative site
that's absent are massed in the the
green site that is present and so if you
have a mrna population that varies in
insist sequences a message like number
one doesn't contain any specific cysts
elements that allow differential binding
to the ribosomal subunits and so you
would expect that this message would be
translated with equal efficiency by all
three types of Barabbas ohms message
like number two which contains binding
site for the positive site in the
ribosome the green green you would
expect the translation could be enhanced
in by ribosome a and B but it wouldn't
be by by the third ribosome which which
doesn't have that cited accessible or
available a third message with a binding
site for a negative element in the
ribosome clue would be down-regulated by
ribosomes a and C but not by B and so as
I mentioned we spent a bit of time
looking at ribosomal RNA interactions
and and so kind of the the first example
the first real example of this was
assigned Ogar no interaction in e.coli
and and so that this was was named after
the scientists who identified this
sequence John shine lyndell bernal and
and so in this interaction there's a
curing rich sequence the shine-dalgarno
sequence that's loaded located upstream
of the initiation codon name of the
Messiah mean initiation quota the AEG
and since this sequence can base pair to
the ribosome to the small ribosomal
subunit to the three prime end of the
16s ribosomal RNA which contains a
complementary
permitting rich sequence and and so this
interaction this sequence allows the
message to bind to the ribosome and to
initiate translation efficiently and so
mutations in the sharing of our no
sequence disrupt the binding so the
ribosome doesn't bind to the message and
also disrupts the translation now the
way they established that this was a
real interaction a real base pairing
interaction was by showing that
intentions of the senator colonel
sequence which disrupted binding and
disrupted translation could function to
enhance translation if the 16s ribosomal
RNA was mutated in a compensatory way so
that he could now base pair to the
mutated sequence and so by performing
these kinds of compensating mutations
they provided it is he human de Bourgh
Hooper had very strong evidence that
this type of a base pairing interaction
was actually occurring and so a long
time it was it was thought that these
types of base pairing interactions were
restricted to bacteria but we had seen
many examples of many mRNAs that contain
these types of sequences in pencil we
investigated a little bit further and
and so one of the first messages at
remember the first but one of the
messages that we studied head of the
most intensively comes from the GTA GTX
homeodomain mrna this is a sequence that
we had identified the complementary
sequence match to the 18s ribosomal RNA
zhilie the RNA component of the small
40s ribosomal subunit in mammalian cells
and what we did was we showed that this
Phi prime leader the Phi prime leader of
the gtx mRNA could function as an
internal ribosome entry site we try to
define the boundaries of this iris but
we found that we
we weren't actually able to do that it
turned out that the five prime leader
had a modular composition in the
different different segments of this
parameter could function independently
to enhance translational function as as
iris elements and so the the one I
resettlement that was complimentary to
the ribosomal RNA his children is shown
here so that we show that this
particular sequence could function
independently as an internal ribosome
entry site we also showed that it could
enhance translation in the context of a
capped mRNA so above the level of the
cap and so that we then termed it a
translation enhancing element or a TV
and we were able to show that by linking
together multiple copies of this
particular element we were able to
dramatically enhance protein synthesis
which formed basically some of the
thinking behind kind of the clustering
mechanism of initiation and and so the
sorts of sorts of studies we were
performed with the GTX involved
everything from binding to manipulation
of the sequence to genetic studies and
so we should we showed that the degree
of complementarity in this message was
correlated with activity and so maximal
activity was able to be achieved with
seven nucleotides if the complementary
match was longer or shorter the activity
progressively fell off and that's
consistent with the idea that if you
have two stable and interaction you may
sequester and be inefficient at
translation and it's too short you just
are not efficient at recruiting and
these
that correlation was was supported by
binding assays where we show that as the
complementary match became longer it
actually bounced the subunits of more
strongly supporting the idea that the
longer interactions might be too stable
using different approaches we're able to
localize the complementary match was
found in the in the platform of the
small subunit so its location is
comparable to the region of the the anti
Shander bernal sequence in bacteria and
in to really determine whether this was
a base pairing interaction we wanted
some genetic evidence of a type
performed in e.coli and at the time
there wasn't a suitable mammalian system
available for performing these studies
and so we performed studies in weeks and
so in the yeast the comparable region of
the nice to ribosome did not have a
continent same complementary match to
the GTX element and we found that the
GTX element was an act of in yeast or we
found that if we introduced a
complementary match into the yeast 18s
ribosomal RNA we could we could obtain
activity and we did this in him in
several different ways we also showed
that mutations that disrupted the GTX
sequence disrupted activity but we were
able to restore activity by introducing
the compensating mutation into the
ribosome morning so anyway this five
times five different so five different
sequence elements that no longer
function with the wild-type ribosome
only function to it he specifically
mutated ribosome and so that this this
provided evidence that the GTX was
interacting by a base pairing mechanism
so more recent example that we've worked
on is is the HC bi or hepatitis C and so
this is this this virus has an RNA
genome that sun capped at
single-stranded it's a major cause
severe liver disease and it expresses a
single long polypeptide that thing gets
processed into into the proteins of the
virus needs and and this this RNA
contains an IRS and this iris is kind of
special it can be directly bind to the
40s ribosomal subunit it's an uncapped
RNA doesn't require the cap binding
complex to recruit the ribosome some of
your studies have shown that it does
require an interaction with a ribosomal
protein in the subunit s25 and other
studies have shown that this iris can
involve the if' three complex of
initiation factors but but it is a
direct binding mechanism and the
the iris can then facilitate initiation
in the presence of the initiator trna
which comes along with the ternary
complex and so some of our studies have
shown that the iris interact with with
the different components of the
ribosomal subunit and an interaction
with the 18s ribosomal RNA was shown and
and so this this figure kind of
illustrates the the sequences of
nucleotides that are binding in the 18s
ribosomal RNA and in the HCV iris and so
there's there's the three bases CCC in
the art and the Rebs morning GGG in the
binding so it was very short I mean by
itself would not be capable of
recruiting the the ribosome and the you
know the severity there's no functional
evidence that there was a real base pair
of interaction there there was there was
evidence that this was an important
interaction mutations for example of the
bottom of the binding site in hcv iris
disrupted activity disrupted binding to
the to the ribosome the binding shown to
protect the nucleotides at least ccc GGG
nucleotides and so there were there was
evidence that these sequences vine and
the combining is important what was
missing was evidence that it was
actually base pairing and because you
can imagine that mutations of the iris
could disrupt the iris by some other
mechanism
and so to do this analysis we use the N
18s rrna expression system that we had
developed earlier and so this is a
mammalian expression system it it has we
have used the yeast expression system
earlier for the GTX analysis this one
has an advantage because it has a
mutation that confers resistance to the
antibiotic pacta meissen and and so what
this enables you to do is express a
mutated ribosomal RNA and in the
presence of the antibiotic which is very
permeable this this particular
antibiotic you're able to disrupt the
translation from the wild-type ribosomal
subunits and monitor expression from the
recombinant emptiness or something as
containing accommodating Tina's rrnas
and then this is a nice system because
it also allows you to look at mutations
that that might be lethal if the cell
had to survive using the drazens and so
this this schematic shows what the
synthetic RNA looks like it it contains
as I mentioned a mutation that confers
pata mice and resistance it also it also
has a hybridization tag so this is a
sequence that we introduced into the
into the ribosomal RNA to enable us to
differentiate between ribosomes that
contain the wild type and recombinant
18s rrna the construct at the bottom
here is what we used for much of the
analysis of the HCV and it contains a
CMV promoter driving expression of a
dice s tronic mrna so this seminar na
expresses renilla luciferase by a cap
dependent mechanism it also expresses
the firefly felt innocence if aires by
an iris dependent mechanism and the ID
iris
located between the two sister on so in
the interest astronics pace and so the
expression of the latinos luciferase
depends on the HCV IRS and so the first
thing we did was try to establish that
the recombinant 18s ribosomal RNA could
translate from the HCV iris of the iris
could direct translation through these
recombinant ribosomes and so we
performed an experiment you can see here
that they construct containing the
wild-type is expressed in a fairly good
level compared to MSC which is multiple
cloning site that there's nothing to
control it's about a 10 full of
difference now individual appointment
ations in the binding site for GGG come
to g to see in tations all disrupted the
activity they disrupted activity to a
level approximately the same as that of
another notation miss you two to HC
which was previously shown to disrupt
activity to about the same extent as
mutations of the GGG sequence so they
suggested that at least our experimental
system was it was a viable and so the
next thing we did was to mutate the
complementary binding site in the 18s
ribosomal RNA CCC sequence and so here
we've introduced point mutations we've
also he also mutated the you before the
new before the CCC because if there was
some evidence of that sequence was was
also protected upon binding of the iris
to be to the ribosome and so we have
four different mutations and in each
case these mutations disrupt the
activity of the of the iris compared to
the wild-type 18s ribosomal RNA now to
show that this increase in expression
was not simply due to a disruption in
ribosomal function
just poorly functioning ribosomal fully
assembled subunit we tested other
sequences so we tested the polio virus
iris and you can see that it's
translated with about the same same
efficiency by the wild-type and by the
mutated variants of the 18s ribosomal
RNA same same with the encephalomyelitis
virus iris quicker paralysis virus iris
the interest s tronic region just the
background levels with the multiple
cloning site were unaffected same with
we will put a beta globin family during
the Exorcist ronik region and cap
dependent translation as monitored by
the expression of renilla luciferase
which would be capped dependent appeared
to be unaffected by by these mutation
suggesting the physical ribosomes are
functioning properly and the effects
that we had seen on the last slide word
were specific now to take a one step
further and establish the base pairing
we generated a series of 18s ribosomal
RNA constructs mutated in the complement
evident in the binding site in the
complementary region at one two or three
nucleotides and then so these are these
are indicated here you know m12 m9 now
if you if you look at the expression
data the qualities mutations result in
an inability of the subunits that
contain them to translate from the HDD
iris and so so then what we did was we
introduced point mutations into the iris
itself to compensate for one of these
mutation and so for example here hcv m14
the company the compensating 18s
ribosomal RNA is this one in orange this
m2 and so you can see that when a
ribosome containing that
point mutation is used to translate the
HDD iris that contains this mutation
there is expression yes I'm back
slightly better than the weapon whereas
the wild-type and the other mutated
ribosomes don't translate that message
similarly we were able to compensate
other point mutations in the HCV iris we
were able to compensate mutations in the
GGG secret so the GGG CC single base
pair in region we were not able to
compensate the mutations of the you and
so interesting that these is a
alternative base pairing combinations
are actually more active than the
wild-type sequence and suggesting it for
the 19's the wild-type sequence is
somehow constraining the activity of
this of this iris so some of these
experiments strongly indicate that the
HCV IRS requires a base pairing
interaction with the 18s ribosomal RNA
for its activity now we know that it's
it also requires represented protein s
25 millimeter or other interactions and
so it's a business as a kind of a nice
and interesting example because in it it
shows an element that by itself would
not be capable of recruiting the
ribosome but functions as part of a
multi interaction event which is which
facilitates the activity which if you
think about it really kind of broadens
the potential scope of these sorts of
interactions and their their
significance so I mean there are a lot
of other examples that recently there's
quite a few papers that have been coming
out let's support the notion of
ribosomal regulation from not going to
giving them
I'll just point out a few that have some
interesting features so there was a
study this year from schlosser and
colleagues and what they showed that was
that methylation of the rebel you mrna a
one-year competitive and this is in
least 25 s which is the kind of the
major RNA component of the large
ribosomal subunit can have differential
effects on translation so whether the
ribosome has this methylation aventyl or
not can affect the translation of a
subset of the my name is very
interesting so they're very interesting
and that this is a affecting translation
through the larger episomal subunit
another example through the larger
episode's almost subunit has to do with
the translation of some Hawks mrnas
which which could function as iris
elements and they can affect translation
of these genomes have very important
functions and development and appear to
be mediated by an interaction with
ribosomal protein l38 again large
ribosomal subunit sentences this is very
interesting another the last example I
want to mention is the study execute
milk from lean weitzman in 2012 and this
is a very interesting example it's an e
coli but it but it shows that mRNA
ribosomal RNA interaction kanka mediate
ribosomal pausing and this is journeying
on Gatien right and so what they found
is that the major cross site in e.coli
is it's basically the sign of learning
interaction and so that that same sort
of interaction between the mRNA and the
ribosome can stall ribosomes and they
did some very convincing study studies
using orthogonal represents to show that
that this is the case and I think this
is very interesting because it kind of
extends the
the notion of ribosomal regulation from
being restricted to initiation to also
being an important potentially important
regulator during you engage and housing
is important for protein folding for
example and so just just to kind of
convened a group running out of time so
it's open this notion of ribosomes
regulation and sorts of studies that
have been done suggest that different
modifications of the ribosome can have
specific effects on an mrna translation
and it shows that the ribosomes is
modifiable at better various points and
so that this kind of raises the
possibility if we kind of take a step
the arm looks natural and you can we can
be begin to modify the ribosome further
for other functions or enhancing certain
functions and and so you can imagine
that a good way to go about doing this
might be to to start looking at the
expansion segments as I mentioned
earlier these are highly variable
regions of the ribosomal RNA it tend to
be located on the surface outsider and
go to the core regions at least the
bacteria they seem to be tolerant to
insertion or some of our own preliminary
study suggests that union can actually
get rid of some of the expansion
segments will without significantly
affecting ribosomal function and and so
these these sequences provide an
opportunity perhaps to introduce
different sorts of RNA Cardinals into
into ragas ohms and there's a the thing
that should be kept in mind is it if you
might be able to do something fairly
significant using this approach because
represent warranties are amongst the
most abundant rnase in cells
and I think that's that's not to
concluding remarks and so what I would
have talked to you about today is you
know the role of ribosomes kind of one
step beyond protein synthesis kind of
their regular tear the potential
regulatory roles examples where they do
appear to affect translation of specific
mrnas and what's interesting is we had
initially predicted that most of the
regulatory effects would be through the
small subunit we thought that it could
occur through the large as well but it
looks like examples are coming in both
large and small and so it's it's it's
nice to see that both subunits are
affecting the translation and
interesting to understand more about how
these interactions with the large
subunit are mediating their effects so
the regulation itself appears to be a
media book by interactions with
ribosomal RNA and with ribosomal
proteins something I didn't bring up
with potential complication with the
ribosomal proteins is that a lot of them
have extra ribosomal functions or
webinar found outside rabaa zones and
you can do things outside of ribosomes
and so that makes that makes the
analysis of those sorts of interactions
are just a little bit more more
complicated but in fact some recent
studies are getting around it and I
think the final step which i think is
very important is that there's no
evidence that wide with ribosomes can
regulate both initiation and at the
local elongation steps of translation
editing at least any cool and different
parts of this work were funded through
the NIH and through funding arrangements
with chromosome and
for some questions let's see so there's
a there's a question from John plant
does paints level themselves have an
impact on how our ribosome will work no
I mean hey it's a good question but I
don't have a good answer and I'm curious
why here's why you're thinking along by
my yeah I don't know okay here is a few
others here on this year the GTX 18s any
spare news are conserved no I didn't
know that that particular sequence is
not conserved as a fat in fact that's
one of the reasons we were able to
perform the study in in the East is
because because that sequence was and
wasn't contained in in the East in the
East system being what comes to play in
different organisms as well is a
stability of different combining rubs or
maybe sparing interactions with the hcv
is for example the there are GU
interactions that are thought to enable
the errors to work with yeast ribosomes
when we did experiments introducing us
they weren't functional and we think
some of that might have to do with
temperature differences have tea Brian
home have teased been developed defined
for plant expression systems
not that i know we have we have not done
that and in although told me what we
have done is many of these maybes
teenies were initially initially
identified in our studies from in East
and when what we noticed is a quite a
few of them were complementary to
different different regions in the the
18s ribosomal RNA and in some cases we
were able to get elements that could
function and mammalian cells by making
sequences complementary to these same
regions in the mammalian 18s ribosomal
RNAs so a sequence that would function
in yeast didn't function in the
mammalian but it would function my name
is complementary we haven't done this
way with plants but I would imagine that
a similar approach would would be
functional yes and let's see Christine
Atkinson does this pausing indicate
further control here this pausing
indicate further control and simply on
off and match well I did not quite sure
I understand the question um I think it
causing indicates that this is an in
this is a this is a event that is
occurring during the elongation during
the actual peptide synthesis to slow the
ribosome at a certain point it's known
that at certain points you often have to
cause a limited to have a
the correct folding of a protein this is
sort of interaction is I think it's
significant for an out for a number of
reasons one of the one of which is that
it illustrates a kind of another level
of information that's encoded in the
coding region of mrnas and for example a
kind of a common approach that's used to
enhance protein expression involves
codon optimizations when you change the
code on user to try to facilitate
protein synthesis and it often involves
getting rid of rare codons and things of
that nature well Harmony's it
harmonizing codon usage from one
organism to another but but when you do
that yet so this is all done using
synonymous codon changes when you do
that this sort of information that might
be encoded in in the primary sequence
these these sorts of for the stretch of
nucleotides that may mediate and the
base Bernie interaction with ribosome is
disrupted right and so you could imagine
that expressing that's sort of an RNA
it's quoted optimized you may get a
different folding pattern in a
particular study they were going to show
that the absence of the fancy chandeleur
no sequence in that in the ribosome
disrupted that the normal pausing
pattern
with you haven't there any more
questions please send them in and I'll
try to answer them I believe that if if
there are other questions later on we
can you can submit those and I'll try to
get back to you through email today's
webcast will be available for on-demand
viewing through November 14 2015 you'll
receive an email from labyrinth alerting
you in this webcast will be available
for replay we invite you to afford that
announcement to your colleagues you may
have missed today's live event see you
next time goodbye